ist das der Deutschland Crash ist es
jedenfalls der Konjunktur Knall
deutschland steuert direkt in die
Rezession es kommt wohl tatsächlich
schlimmer als wir alle dachten denn bei
einer heftigen gasmangellage bei einem
besonders kalten Winter rechnen Forscher
jetzt fürs nächste Jahr mit einem
Konjunktureinbruch um
7,9%. das ist das Ergebnis der Experten
in ihrem Herbstgutachten fast acht
Prozent Abstoß das hat es in der
Bundesrepublik noch nie gegeben und
darüber sprechen wir jetzt bei uns im
Studio mit bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer
schönen guten Tag Jan guten Tag ist das
jetzt der schwarze Donnerstag genau wie
es damals beim Börsencrash den schwarzen
Freitag gegeben hat das eine Prognose
ist eine Prognose der fünf verführenden
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute in
Deutschland und die haben in ihrem
Herbst Gutachten verschiedene Szenarien
untersucht es gibt auch ein gutes
Szenario da kann man fast sagen das
macht Hoffnung dass es ein Szenario das
davon ausgeht dass im nächsten Jahr
alles einigermaßen rund läuft und es
deswegen nur einen sehr sehr leichten
Konjunktureinbruch gibt die Wirtschaft
nur leicht schrumpft um bei 0,5 Prozent
dass das beste Szenario und was wir
gerade auch gesehen haben besprochen
haben dass das schlimmste Szenario in
der Tat wenn es also zu einer
gastmangelage kommt wenn wir wirklich zu
wenig Energie beispielsweise im Winter
haben sollten wenn Firmen ihre
Produktion stilllegen müssen wenn auch
Haushalte nicht mit ausreichend Energie
versorgt werden dann so die Forscher
dann droht hier ein echter Absturz den
wir so in Deutschland noch nicht gesehen
gesehen haben
-8%. was bedeutet der dann für die
Bürger da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
Effekte und eine Sache ist interessant
weil man bisher immer davon ausgegangen
ist dass ein konjunkturabsturz vor allem
in dieser Größenordnung mit dramatischen
Folgen auch für den Arbeitsmarkt dann
einhergegangen wäre muss ich in dem Fall
sagen denn umgekehrt und das ist ganz
ganz interessant in dieser Krise in der
wir uns befinden suchen viele Firmen
immer noch händeringend nach Mitarbeiter
das heißt auf der einen Seite bekommen
sie zu wenig Energie müssen deswegen
möglicherweise ihre Produktion stoppen
aussetzen und
auf der anderen Seite aber so viele
Aufträge dass ich eigentlich noch mehr
Leute einstellen müssten das bedeutet
also natürlich keine Lohnsteigerung
davon können wir uns verabschieden das
ist ganz klar weil der Druck viel zu
groß auf viele Firmen es wird Firmen
Pleiten bedeuten auch aber es wird auch
andere Firmen geben die weiter
Mitarbeiter suchen und einstellt also
wir haben einen zweigeteilten
Arbeitsmarkt ja das ist doch paradox auf
der einen Seite die Auftragsbücher sind
voll die Firmen könnten diese ganzen
Aufträge wahrnehmen also die Wirtschaft
auch Stärken auf der anderen Seite diese
hohe Kostenlast durch die Energiekrise
dass das kaum noch zu bewältigen ist
richtig das ist paradox ein vollkommen
richtiger Hinweis und was ebenfalls
nämlich dann in der Logik auch paradox
ist ist das was die Forschungsinstitute
sagen zur Preisentwicklung im nächsten
Jahr die gehen davon aus dass wir in
diesem Jahr eine Inflation haben von 8,2
Prozent und dass die Preise nächstes
Jahr noch stärker steigen werden im
Durchschnitt als schon in diesem Jahr
die gehen von
8,68,8 Prozent aus also fast neun
Prozent im Jahresschnitt das ist dann
gesehen
mehr als wir in diesem Jahr gehabt haben
und wir wissen alle unter welchem
enormen Druck wir hier schon stehen was
die Preise angeht Energie aber auch beim
täglichen einkaufen und die bitteren
Aussichten sind dass sich das im
nächsten Jahr auf keinen Fall ändern
wird
inwiefern erhöht das jetzt auch den
Druck auf die Politik das erhöht den
Druck auf die Politik extrem die
Bundesregierung würde ich sagen ist
ohnehin schon in einer dramatischen
Situation sie ist wahrscheinlich in der
dramatischsten Situation der eine
Bundesregierung seit Jahrzehnten
überhaupt sein kann denn
die die die die der Druck auf die Bürger
dieser Kostendruck viele viele Menschen
wissen ja nicht wie Sie diese
Energiekosten und dieses teure Leben
noch Schultern sollen aber man kann ja
bei Energie nicht sagen im Winter ich
verzichte einfach mal drauf wie auf zwei
Flaschen Bier in der Kneipe sondern man
muss natürlich seine Wohnung heizen man
braucht den Strom also sind wir hier in
einer echten dramatischen Notlage da ist
die Regierung in einer Notlage und wir
hören bereits von weiteren Paketen die
es geben soll oder vielleicht das Wort
Paket auch nicht wichtig aber von
weiterer Unterstützung im Rahmen von 100
bis möglicherweise sogar 200 Milliarden
Euro gerade in Bezug auf die gasumlage
und da hören wir auch das ist in den
nächsten Stunden da eine Erklärung und
eine Pressekonferenz von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz geben wird und 14 Uhr treten
Scholz Habeck und Lindner gemeinsam vor
die Presse was wird dort erwartet was
wird verkündet es wird erwartet oder wir
erwarten nach einem was wir hören dass
die gasumlage endgültig begraben wird
und dass es noch mal
ein einen ja eine sowas wie eine
gaspreisbremse geben wird die aber dann
ein Volumen haben wird auch für den
Staat in Höhe von mehr als 100
Milliarden Euro was bedeutet
gaspreisbremse das ist nach jetzigem
Stand das was wir wissen dass der
Gaspreis gedeckelt wird und das also für
viele Haushalte ist dann eine Hoffnung
gibt dass sie diese extremen Ausschläge
am Gasmarkt nicht unbedingt in ihrem
Portemonnaie spüren also da eine gewisse
Entlastung eintritt aber ganz klar ist
die muss natürlich irgendwie auch
finanziert werden das ist so ein
bisschen dann linke Tasche rechte Tasche
da geht der Start erstmal in Vorleistung
mit einem großen großen Volumen an Geld
aber wir wissen auch das was wir uns
heute auf Pump leisten als Steuerzahler
als Bürger das müssen wir irgendwann
natürlich wieder zurück bezahlen und die
Kosten angesprochen ist das auch das Aus
für die Schuldenbremse
da kommt es drauf an und das ist ja das
Lieblingsprojekt auch der FDP und von
Christian Lindner wie man diese
gaspreisbremse jetzt gestaltet ob man
sagt wir nehmen alle Kosten die anfallen
und buchen Sie in dieses Jahr
beispielsweise in diesem Jahr geht die
Schuldenbremse noch nicht wenn das
technisch möglich ist also
finanztechnisch dann glaube ich wird
Christian Lindner alles versuchen genau
dies zu tun und wenn das nicht möglich
ist dann muss man sicherlich sagen ist
die Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr fast
nicht mehr zu halten eins ist noch
wichtig zu wissen bei der Schuldenbremse
und das ist irgendwie auch etwas ja
ironisch kann fast sagen je schlechter
ist der Wirtschaft geht umso mehr
Schulden kann Christian Lindner auch
machen das heißt wenn wir wirklich ein
Absturz haben um fünf sechs oder sieben
Prozent im nächsten Jahr dann hat er
deutlich mehr Spielraum auch um Schulden
zu machen dann könnte er weit über 40
Milliarden Euro Schulden aufnehmen das
würde dann bedeuten er macht deutlich
mehr Schulden aber hält ironischerweise
trotzdem die Schuldenbremse ein und um
14 Uhr treten Scholz Habeck Lindner dann
vor besser wir übertragen das natürlich
live hier bei Bild live vielen Dank für
den Moment an bildpolitikchef Jan
Schäfer
minus 7,9 Prozent fast acht Prozent das
ist eine Ansage hat es so in Deutschland
noch nicht gegeben wir haben sie gefragt
glauben Sie dass Sie in einem Jahr noch
einen Job haben werden
wahrscheinlich nicht also glaube ich
nicht also
wählt sich so endet in der momentanen
Zeiten also ich glaube es sieht ganz
schlecht aus wenn ich ehrlich bin
glaubst du dass du nächstes Jahr noch
einen Job hast gehen wir vom Besten aus
ja ich glaube schon darf ich fragen
welchen Bereich arbeitest du
Immobilienwirtschaft und ich denke
Immobilien wird immer weitergegeben die
werden auch immer bewirtschaftet werden
es wird immer gebaut werden sondern die
Frage in welchem Umfang gebaut wird aber
ich denke schon
dass wir ein relativ sicheren Job haben
ich habe nächstes Jahr noch einen Job ja
aber nicht in Deutschland sicher nicht
in Deutschland
Holland aber was machen sie da ich bin
therapies ja
die können wir auch gut gebrauchen ja
stimmt auch wenn die Wirtschaft so um 8%
einbricht nächstes Jahr wie es jetzt
gemeldet wird ja gut das war kettet sich
kann Konsequenzen an unsere Arbeit auch
haben wir sind Metallbauer
aber ich denke mir oder ich bin mir 90%
sicher dass zumindestens bei uns Arbeit
gibt so dass es mit einem Job noch
relativ sicher ist ja es wird
wahrscheinlich ein härteres Umfeld aber
ich glaube schon dass wir weiterhin Job
haben ja zu tun ist auf jeden Fall genug
ich glaube nicht wenn es so weitergeht
glaube ich
werde alles jetzt katastropisch
[Musik]